[laughter]
dear colleagues, dear colleagues, dear
colleagues, dear
professor rock
stromen, dear excellencies, ladies
and gentlemen,
a colleague once said to me
that the actual activity of
a foreign minister is about
overcoming borders,
he said that  first of all, quite
literally, every trip abroad begins
with crossing a border and
exclusion is the first step towards
the need for foreign policy,
colleague, but he also wanted to get at something
else, namely that
foreign policy must above all be
mentally flexible, if only we could
too  overcome the limits in our heads
that
still exist and
maybe that is more important today than ever
the challenges of our time
digitization globalization
migration climate change all have one thing in
common they know no borders
and therefore purely national ones are enough today
answers to all these challenges are
no longer sufficient
and nowhere is this as clear as
with climate change
when sea level rises smog
pollutes the air entire countries dry out
or are flooded regions
the size of german federal
states are on fire then this is not a problem for a single state or a single
region  it affects all of us
where people's
livelihoods are threatened
conflicts are inevitable that started as an
ecological challenge
has long since
become a question of security and
stability in many places ladies and
gentlemen the countries of central asia and
afghanistan are particularly badly affected by
climate change
i  we're not just talking about the retreat of the
lake the
danger of landslides, avalanches and
floods has increased everywhere in the region
extreme weather conditions are becoming more and more common
let's just think of the long drought in 2018
or the recent cold wave in
afghanistan many people  some died in the process and
many had to leave their homeland
if climate change knows no borders then
our response to it must no
longer know any borders
with my country first we do
n't get very far in
the end it means that when it comes to
our common livelihoods, nobody
else does  against everyone
we have therefore made the
security policy consequences of
climate change, which have long been a
priority of our membership in
the united nations security
council, we are now
being supported by a group of friends in
which 48 countries, including afghanistan, are already
participating and i would
be very happy if they  the
states of central asia would also join this group of
friends on climate and
security their regional
experience would be a great enrichment for our work there
, because after
all they are going together with kriens
angeles like the idea of ​​climate
-related security risks regi  dealing with water across borders also
makes your region a role model
for other countries and the foundation
for such cooperation has existed
for more than ten years thanks to the
central asia water initiative, a
project of the so-called berlin
process, and this has made the issue of
water a sensitive one  contentious issue
a conflict friction now on a topic
for cross-border
understanding you all know better than me how
great the potential for conflict was just a
few years ago let's
think about the distribution
conflicts between water-rich countries on the
upper reaches of rivers and those on
the lower reaches of rivers that face water
shortages and so on  more remarkable because the
summit meeting in 2018, at which all
central asian countries jointly
considered how to
cooperate better in regional water management
, but developments in recent years have also shown that we have to position
ourselves more broadly
water is only one part  the complex
reality that climate change
presents us with is about melting glaciers,
desertification and the loss of
farmland and the effects of all
these developments on
food security and also migration
we also have to adjust to the consequences of
climate change, which we have been dealing with for a
long time  in order not only
to be able to react, we have to do that,
we have to recognize the risks
earlier, evaluate them and draw the right
conclusions from them
and we have to invest in resilience in the
resilience of the
affected people and
that's exactly what green century
students and I are about  I'm glad that we
have competent
comrades-in-arms the experts from the potsdam institute for
climate research or the
geo-research center and ladies
and gentlemen behind gries angeles there
is another clear principle, namely that
the networking networking between politicians, economists
and w  scientists and
civil society networking but also
between germany and the
central asian states and
afghanistan and and us this
cooperation is particularly important
and we believe in the great potential of
their countries and their young
population and we have a great
interest in sustainable stability and
growth in the  whole region and
that is why we have been so committed to
the eu central asia strategy
and i am particularly pleased that
josef borel is here today and with
his presence gives this topic
a very special importance for the european union
and because we are also a member country  the
european union feel every day how
important regional integration is.
we would also like to support central
asia in defining and representing its interests as a region more strongly than before and it is of course no coincidence that afghanistan is here
today along with
all of your countries  t are
divided by borders, also by the political
upheavals of recent years and
decades
i am firmly convinced that they have
much more in common than they separate
a long history of cultural
historical heritage common
water resources and of course the
challenges of climate change
that is why it is so important to us that  the
cooperation of the central
asian states with afghanistan in terms of
infrastructure, economy or education
has developed in recent years
we will continue to support it
because you are pursuing the same goals of
security and stability in and around
afghanistan and sustainable
economic development in the
region in short we want  create the conditions
for peace and prosperity
and that's why we
launched the eu-asia connectivity strategy a good year ago.
it's about improving the expansion of
connections and networks across the
continent,
basic  erend on common rules and, above
all, geared towards
sustainability, be it through a project
like the green ports on the caspian sea
or through the expansion of the digital network, the
closer we are the closer the people in their
regions are connected to each other, the
more we can find common
solutions  central asia played a if not the central role not
only in name but also because of
its location between europe russia and
china and south
asia ladies and gentlemen when i
just talked about
sustainability and in this context
one thing is very important to me again
to point out
that this conference here today must
not be a flash in the pan and that is why it
is also embedded in a process
that we are continuing to shape together
with you today. we want to talk about it today
and a next step
is already certain, namely the second
berlin climate in security conference on
15 and  16 june here in berlin to
which we would like to cordially invite you today, but in the end our initiative will not have to be measured by the number of international conferences, but by what we
implement together, across borders. the
fact that they all came today shows
me  that you did exactly that and i
think that was what my
foreign minister colleague meant when he spoke about how
foreign policy overcomes borders
thank you very much for being here today and for being willing to do so
and now josef los is
yours
[laughter]
ladies and gentlemen sexual  lawrenz
the minister would have the minister manager
germany minister
from hosting the import an conference
all for me to participate and happy to
see so many friends hu mat trip from
central asian afghanistan to be here
today the strategy & central asia what
you  depot in june unexpectedly to new
strategy & central asian in freising and
positive dynamics in greece in
newport you need is for cooperation june
and cs the region as a partner jürgen
burst you eat and west north ag the board
of the new game center one to the
majority of diplomacy corruption a
do have a strong commitment like the
european junior in order to balance the
regional bus lines and central asia
on youtube from the original cooperation
prohibited this message and thus
settle on centro november in
taschkent
collective action requirements and
russia today the effects of climate
change of america 20 east africa some
racing series all you need is it is at
john williams and  it comes in
red before the young union is committed
to make you tube the first climate
could at 1050 the sau julien green
day like all this is from the
pharmaceutical industry
bishop is full
with michael wolf and climate
diplomacy manunited
frost provider space for regional
cooperative solutions today we can do
with it platforms cooperation with
standing ovations
inclusion is dan  n not that alone
would initiative of the balls then it
goes to pakistan
in fergana wally with a very ugly betty
martius problem smoothes legacy on june
for my place in mainz according to amor amor
frequent like cost of climate change a
thing is then the world trigger the
disastrous spread of the chicken
radioactive plutonium lakers on
the part of the federation mb as a concern term natural
disaster
this is european junior the cheap
money for gold must have danny s supporting
greece program to find a way
solutions from rhenium lakers in the
west as well as bridal fashion photo million before the
same  monz moscow climate change is
a politician challenge effekt duos
[music]
using our expertise and resources to do
diaz in action we help so cheer up
[applause]